hi there Steve Kaufman I hope you're
enjoying your holidays I was asked by
one of my viewers if my approach to
language learning or my method of
language learning has changed over the
years so I thought I would try to answer
that question today by the way if some
of you would like to hear me speak in
other languages let me know and tell me
which language I don't do this so much
to demonstrate because I'm gonna be a
pretty rusty and some of them but if
some of you have trouble understanding
me in English I am quite happy to
attempt to explain things in other
languages let me know however the
question is has my method or my approach
to language learning change and the
answer is no so if we look first of all
at French which I had going through
elementary school high school not
interested potentially I could have been
immersed in French living in Montreal
but I wasn't interested when I went to
university I had a professor who made it
interesting I don't have copies of those
books that we used but they were very
good they just turned me on to French
culture and then I went at it I looked
for things that interested me and I did
a lot of listening and reading and of
course then I went off to France and I
studied there and I of course used the
language every day Chinese I was as some
of you may know I was sent to Hong Kong
by the Canadian government to learn
Chinese again the whole emphasis was on
listening and reading and doing things
that were meaningful to me and so in
addition to our course content I sought
out all kinds of readers I have a vast
you know library bookshelf of Chinese
books with vocabulary notes per chapter
literature history you name it and I
don't think any of the other students
did that and whenever I could get a hold
of any audio material including young
strong material economic dialogues I
would listen to that so that has always
been my approach when I moved to Japan
even though I was potentially immersed
in the language I spent an awful lot of
time listening and reading lots of other
people who lived in Japan
didn't take advantage in order for me to
be able to take advantage of that
environment that surrounded me I had to
bring my level up and that I did through
listening and reading of course I would
interact with people at an earlier stage
because I was right there so in a store
or wherever I had to try to use whatever
I had but those were meaningful
exchanges in the language I am not that
fond of having an artificial exchange
for the sake of having an exchange if
I'm where the language is spoken that's
a meaningful exchange then I get into it
and that becomes meaningful content so
none of that has changed what has
changed dramatically is the kind of
tools that are available so when I was
doing Chinese I had books I don't know
if it's worth showing I've shown them
before yeah you know I still have it
Chinese lectures at least 20 lectures in
Chinese culture don't go on fire show
John great simplified to some extent I
mean we had traditional characters that
you probably can't see that but there
were first of all we had the text in
pinyin we had like we had audio for it
and we had vocabulary lists per chapter
then I moved to this other excellent
book called intermediate reader in
modern Chinese which is just excellent
and there we're dealing with authentic
texts that was after three or four
months authentic text by Jo and live by
Mao Zedong bahu short and ample a
vocabulary list plus explanations not
explanations but it's pointing out the
structures you know I'm not gonna grab
but just one each on madama nehi schism
Adama or you know yo-yo ma whatever of
course in their explanations they were
full of v I looked at it you know the
ps1 diagrams this is a predicate this is
ever I never looked at any of that stuff
I just wanted to get a sense of the
structure this is the structure this is
how they say it and so that has always
been my approach but what has changed
now is and I'll quickly flat you know
not flash backwards but fast forward to
day from let's say 1974 1968-69
when I was studying Chinese in those
days I had this big open real tape
recorders alright and I look for books
that had vocabulary lists with each
chapter because looking things up in a
dictionary was so time-consuming and
hopeless today for example you know I I
happen to be watching television and
there's a Danish mu Danish movie called
a royal affair which is about the ruins
a period when there was a Mad King King
Christian in Denmark and it's a very
it's a lovely movie and I was trying
desperately to try and understand the
Danish but it was just too difficult
it's it's sufficiently different from
Sweden Swedish and it was just hard to
understand in the movie but it's a great
movie and I happen to have bought that
that's a Swedish novel and I happen to
have bought that novel in the 80s or
early 90s when I was working on my
Swedish and I haven't yet read it I
bought so many books that I don't read
sometimes so on up and had a look at it
and then I said wow that must exist in
eBook form so I then scoured the
Internet and was able to buy an e-book
the ebook comes in the ePub format which
I then put in the calibre this program
that I have that converts it into a text
format the text format then is a format
that I can import into link because my
vocabulary in Swedish because I was
there doing business and stuff for a lot
of stuff reading literature and so forth
there's a lot of missing words so I
would rather read this book in Swedish
on link where I can look up the words
and I have no trouble remembering them
because my Swedish is actually not that
bad even though I I'm missing some words
so it's not I say hey there must be an
audio book for this so I searched for
the audio book it turns out that audio
Pekka which I have already used for
Polish and for Czech and which has an
app that you install on your iPhone well
they have a Swedish version of audio
teka and lo and behold they have this
book which is called leave Lakeland's
beserk in Swedish so I download the
audio I now have it on my iPhone it's
not on my iPhone
it's being streamed but I can access it
by my iPhone so I can now access my
Russian history by a Coonan in Russia
from my iPhone I can access polish and
Czech resources Swedish resources from
my iPhone
meanwhile the texts I upload in the link
and I can read them I don't have to look
for vocabulary you know readers with
vocabulary notes or whatever so my
ability to study at any time wherever I
am to connect with polish Swedish you
know to read material where I can click
the lookup words that I don't know and
then I see them highlighted in yellow I
mean all of that has changed
dramatically but the basic principle
that it's going to be like stephen
krashen says it's going to be meaningful
content that will enable you to learn
the language you might trigger that
meaningful content by having a
conversation with someone meaningful
content for you might be music might be
German rock music that's not what
interests me but it has to be meaningful
content and if you are getting messages
you know words content that's meaningful
meaningful means you're interested and
you're able to understand it it might be
that you have to look up words in order
to understand it but again just
listening is something this noise is not
meaningful it has to be meaningful
interesting and yet you're kind of able
to understand it or can get where you
understand it that's what's gonna make
you learn the language once you accept
that then for example I'm doing some
Polish history and it's interesting I'm
enjoying reading about Polish history
I'm looking up words I'm not concerned
about my progress I mean yeah adlink we
record how many words are know and stuff
yeah Allah tells me as I'm busy I'm
doing something with the language I'm
reading I'm listening I know that I will
gradually acquire the language by doing
this I am not at all under any pressure
I just understand what I understand some
parts may be a little fuzzy but I can
look things up and and I'm enjoying it
I'm enjoying it I'm learning so I guess
the only difference between now and when
I studied let
a Chinese is that when I was doing
Chinese I was under pressure because I
was being paid by the government to
learn Chinese that was my job
other than that now I'm under no
pressure I guess when I lived in Japan I
was under some pressure to get my
Japanese level up so that I could use it
for business now when I'm doing Russian
or Ukrainian reports I'm under no
pressure whatsoever I'm enjoying it but
the basic principle that its massive and
I should point out by the way that
that's more or less what I said in my
book this happens to be the Chinese
version of my book called the linguist a
language learning Odyssey it was
published in China and Taiwan by the way
and this was written about ten years ago
nothing that I said in here has changed
the just the technology has changed
though the the ability to do these
things has become so much better ten
years ago to today it hasn't changed and
from fifty years ago to today it hasn't
changed those are still the basic
principles and so in answer I hope that
answers the question that someone asked
on my website or at least on the on
YouTube here thank you for listening and
let me know if you would like me to
speak in some other language bye for now